[Music]  Justin Bieber beats the Bur with the fur  [Music]  cooped up in a hooded coyote style coat  Bebe's head up West Hollywood hotspot  heights sunset justin completed the look  with tan boots and acid-washed jeans but  those glasses were given us some serious  office space flashbacks that would be  great don't expect an apology not JB  style the chill aside a source tells et  that Bieber was in great spirits while  rocking his over-the-top fur jacket the  source adds that the Seekers  ex-girlfriend hailey Baldwin was also  there apparently they talked but arrived  and left separately makes sense he did  tell Ellen he's single  [Applause]  [Music]  you